I found out my girlfriend was a
prostitute
oh my God
I 32 recently found out that my 29 year
old female girlfriend has been working
for sags on and off the last nine years
my girlfriend and I have been dating for
three months and everything is great we
have great chemistry and have a lot in
common I believe she's the one I want to
marry until last weekend we went out
with the friends for drinks last
Saturday and got drunk my friend fell
asleep while her friends and I continued
talking and drinking her best friend
accidentally had a tongue slip and told
me that my girlfriend had a lot more
sexual experience than me my girlfriend
was a stripper when she was 20 and had
sex often with clients she did this on
and off for nine years her friend knows
this because she also worked with her
I'm horrified and disgusted I don't know
what to do